[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 1er
décembre du tutorat pour développer un
nouveau modèle pédagogique la fondation
pour agir contre l'exclusion vient de
lancer une action de parrainage avec
l'entreprise thalès basé à elancourt une
opération qui profite à dix huit
collégiens de trappes qui pourront ainsi
mieux appréhender le monde de
l'entreprise dominique tristan est notre
invité fil rouge pour cette émission
nous évoquons avec le directeur de la
ferme pédagogique de grignon l'actualité
autour du glyphosate et les solutions
développées localement pour un modèle
agricole plus responsable enfin dans le
reste de l'actualité retour sur la
concertation sur le réaménagement du
centre-ville de plaisir ou la semaine de
la citoyenneté à magny les hameaux
renforcer le lien entre l'école et le
monde professionnel c'est la volonté
d'une action de manteaux ring lancé
jeudi au quai au collège
gustave-flaubert de trappes 18 salariés
de l'entreprise de thales vont parrainer
18 élèves durant toute l'année scolaire
pour leur permettre de découvrir le
monde de l'entreprise une opération
coordonnée par la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion reportage d'aurélie rose
s'il s'en tient à l'air un peu perdu
c'est parce qu'elle est à la recherche
de sa marraine
comme ces dix sept camarades elle s'est
portée volontaire pour en apprendre
davantage sur l'entreprise thalès basé à
elancourt ce projet en fait nous
j'ouvre au monde extérieur surtout au
monde professionnel et ça nous fait un
grand carnet d adresse puisque caen en
troisième
on n'a pas beaucoup de contact avec le
monde extérieur chaque parrain ou
marraine a reçu un kit avec un contrat
d'engagement qui permet de formaliser ce
tutorat il prévoit notamment un rendez
vous mensuel
ça apporte une vraie valeur humaine
aussi parce que l'on s'intéresse à leur
projet à ce qu'ils veulent faire ce
qu'ils font déjà dans la vie que ça soit
au collège grandeur du collège leur
activité ça permet un échange
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'un
partenariat est conclu entre
l'entreprise thales et le collège
gustave courbet l'an dernier les deux
établissements avaient collaboré dans le
cadre du projet grain d'entreprise en
fait les salariés sont dit pourquoi pas
s'engager auprès d'élèves pour un peu
travaillé leur orientation et ce sur
peut-être plusieurs années donc
l'objectif c'est que là là on fait le
lancement des binômes exerce à elle
jusqu'à l'obtention du brevet et voire
même du pack
on a des gens qui sont passionnés d'un
groupe thales donc on va pouvoir créer
ses relations entre le salarié et
l'élève pour le faire découvrir une
vocation peut-être dans thales au delà
de la découverte des filières industrie
et technique
cette action a également pour objectif
de construire un parcours d'orientation
scolaire et de développer chez les
collégiens un esprit d'initiative
l'actualité de cette fin de semaine
c'est aussi un chiffre 25000 25000
personnes ignorent en france qu'elles
sont séropositives une donnée en écho
évidemment à la journée internationale
de lutte contre le sida et qui inquiète
alors que 6000 nouvelles personnes sont
contaminées par le virus
chaque année se pose donc la question de
la prévention à trappes l'association hf
prévention multiplient elles les actions
sur le terrain et se développe dans le
numérique avec le lancement d'une
nouvelle application virus war 2 vous
voyez les images le
digital un moyen de prévention devenu
essentiel pour toucher les plus jeunes
comme l'expliqué sur notre plateau lundi
le directeur de l'association on l'est
on a dans le top line 3 4 games 'changer
sur la santé des femmes
1 / effectivement tout ce qui va être
contraception et aussi sur la nutrition
parce qu'aujourd'hui on se rend bien
compte qu'il faut aller au devant des
gens avec des tests avec des autotests
mais aussi avec des nouvelles techniques
on voit tu peux tu peux aujourd'hui
c'est un formidable support préservatif
qui présageait un lieu de dépistage
partout en france et 200 mille
utilisateurs réguliers qu'ils ont dans
leur poche
la marraine c'est marina carrère
d'encausse du journal de la santé de
france 5
et c'est vrai qu'on le voit bien ça
répond à une nécessité aujourd'hui on
est dans le digital
il convient de faire de la prévention
nouvelles générations de la prévention
digital la france promet d'arrêter avant
l'europe le glyphosate disparaîtra du
modèle agricole d'ici trois ans et le
message des manuels macron cette semaine
alors que l'union européenne a renouvelé
la licence de cette molécule
ô combien polémique pour cinq ans mettre
fin à l'utilisation du glyphosate en
2020 est ce possible comment doit-on
basculer dans un modèle plus responsable
nous allons tenter de répondre à ces
questions avec notre invité fil rouge de
blicquy attristant bon soit on sera vous
êtes le directeur de la ferme
expérimentale de grignon et président
aussi de l'association à terre des
yvelines vous êtes clairement engagée
dans une démarche environnementale sur
la plaine de versailles
est ce que vous pensez vous qu'il y
avait beaucoup plus de légitimité que
beaucoup de gens qu'on entend sur le
sujet que la france pourra avancer
voisins se passait totalement du
glyphosate en 2020 est ce qu'elle aura
les moyens de le faire concrètement
alors si ça va dans la soirée dans une
opération communication
je pense qu'on est dans une opération de
com après si c'est réglementaire il
faudra bien que les agriculteurs s'y
tiennent
donc aujourd'hui des solutions
techniques pour limiter la consommation
dans 100% des cas là est la question
vous voulez dire que peut-être que c'est
un un coup de pression mise sur les sur
les sur les acteurs locaux et puis
nationaux du monde agricole pour leur
dire leur fixer un cap et leur dire
après trois ans sinon ça va c'est un
coup de pression surtout sur le monde
agricole et les filières de première
transformation parce que c'est quand
même là où l'enjeu est après c'est une
prise de conscience collective de quel
modèle agricole
on veut en france soit au niveau du
consommateur et du citoyen aussi alors
rappelons déjà peut-être quelques
chiffres en france l'an passé s'est
vendu huit mille tonnes de glyphosate
ses 700 milles dans le monde est ce que
ça veut dire je ne sais pas si vous avez
une vision sur le monde entier est ce
que ça veut dire que la france peut être
déjà et moins consommatrices de ce type
de produits que les autres pays alors
moins que l'europe
non je ne pense pas même si j'ai pas les
chiffres à moins que des pays où il ya
beaucoup de gm comme les états unis
comme l'argentine comme le brésil oui
très clairement puisque là-bas la
culture des ogm exacerbe en fait la
quantité de glyphosate utilisé puisque
c'est le seul herbicide utilisé pour
toutes les taux des mauvaises herbes sur
beaucoup de culture alors déjà on le
rappelle le glyphosate est interdit pour
les particuliers et ça depuis le 1er
janvier de cette année où il ya quelques
mois la série sans concrètement pour les
agriculteurs si en 2020 il n'y a plus de
glyphosate
qu'est ce que ça change dans la vie dans
le travail qu est-ce qui va devoir être
fait qu'on ne faisait peut-être plus
avant concrètement c'est pour la relance
et les vieilles machines on va relancer
les machines je pense notamment du
travail du sol plus ou moins intensif
puisqu'en fait au lieu de désherber le
chant avec un produit chimique va
falloir enfuir la mauvaise herbe ou
empêcher sa germination avec un travail
du sol répétait pour assécher en surface
donc ça prend du temps ça consomme du
fuel ça émet des gaz à effet de serre ça
veut dire que c'est pas forcément très
bon pour l'environnement
quand on travaille le sol on peut aussi
perturber un petit peu les carabes les
carabes sondés des bêtes qui nous
intéresse nous pour manger les eaux
nîmes associe donc voila tout ne
tournait pas aussi simple que le
glyphosate est mauvais d'un côté et puis
le les solutions san li fu that sont ou
bien est-ce que aussi une vie sans
glyphosate c'est moins de rendement donc
moins de rentrées financières donc on
connaît un peu la difficulté pour les
agriculteurs à vivre de leur métier
est ce que le fait de retirer cet
herbicide que tout le monde semble
dénoncer aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
pas aussi prendre le risque d'appauvrir
d'éventuels agriculteurs ou alors il
faudrait que l'état s'engage à les aider
encore plus alors moindre rendement 8
ponctuellement mais c'est surtout une
hausse des coûts de production
parce qu'on va remplacer ce diplomate
par d'autres techniques qu'elle soit
chaude pour l'emploi oui alors ça c'est
un autre débat puisque dans le monde
agricole va quand même du mal à recruter
je suis de passer à green ont aussi pour
pour le savoir ça mais le la question là
c'est plutôt de se dire finalement si on
regarde 20 ans en arrière le glyphosate
coûter très cher il était très peu
utilisé on avait des solutions
techniques pour le faire mécanique
certes mais aussi chimiques qu'on avait
une diversité d'herbicides homologué
cette diversité d'herbicides aujourd'hui
elle est de plus en plus restreinte
certainement parce que des produits
étaient vraiment dangereux pour la santé
de l'homme et pour l'environnement donc
ils ont été enlevés des listes autorisée
je pense c'est très bien par contre
techniquement son terrain le nombre de
solutions s'est restreinte et le
glyphosate à un moment comme il a baissé
aussi a pris avec l'art est vue du
brevet uniquement détenu par mojito et
bien c'était la solution de facilité de
prendre le glyphosate très pratique
aussi pour trait les pour tuer les
mauvaises herbes
voilà alors par contre un herbicide
total c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
désherber humble et qui a déjà été
semées avec du glyphosate c'est un
désherbage de près semi puisqu'en fait
il est naturel blé mais ça a permis des
techniques
de production à des coûts compétitifs
par rapport à nos compétiteurs
internationaux
on l'a vu les réactions ont été très
nombreux cette semaine notamment des
syndicats agricoles le principal la
fnsea s'est opposée à la vision
française et c'est quelque part à
quelque part salué la décision finale de
l'union européenne qui seront
principalement peiné par un éventuel
arrêt dans trois ans du glyphosate est
ce que ce sont les gros industriels ou
alors eux ils ont les moyens financiers
de pouvoir se retourner ou alors c'est
le petit producteur qui a une trentaine
d'années qui travaille depuis dix ans
avec le glyphosate et lui il va devoir
régénérer totalement sa façon de faire
non alors je crois pas du tout que ce
soit une question de taille petit gros
jeunes ou anciens ça fait que le
glyphosate est intéressant aujourd'hui
sur certaines certains types de sols
certaines cultures et certaines
mauvaises herbes surtout alors quelles
cultures principalement alors si je
prends les mauvaises herbes par exemple
et charbon les chardons c'est compliqué
à s'en débarrasser c'était le chien donc
était utilisé sur lequel des deux est
accusé énormément et c'est vrai qu'on a
quelques mauvaises herbes comme ça bien
cible ou les solutions chimique ou
mécanique sont assez limités même en bio
d'ailleurs le débarrasser des chardons
en bio c'est pas simple et donc le
glyphosate a apporté une solution qui
s'offre en bio bien entendu sur sur ces
arbitres sur ses mauvaises les arrivées
précise donc là vous pouvez en avoir sur
des petites fermes sur des grosses
fermes dans le nord de la france dans le
sien et la france en bretagne
voilà c'est pas c'est pas une question
de taille de ferme c'est une question de
domaniale de type de sol faire aussi pas
forcément une révolution aussi c'est
peut-être le début d'une révolution vous
le disiez c'est ce fameux coup de
pression pour aller dans un modèle plus
plus vert plus raisonnable oui mais le
modèle pubères je veux dire enfin il ya
400 ans il y avait déjà des chardons et
on avait du mal à s'en débarrasser il
n'y avait pas de befoza tu donc le
glyphosate un moment a permis de se
débarrasser des chardons à titre pas la
seule solution suis d'accord mais ça a
permis à titre personnel dans votre
association ou à la ferme est ce que
vous utilisez vous du glyphosate
mais ce que vous en avez utilisé géant
j'en utilise plutôt plus par rapport à
la moyenne française je pense parce que
je suis dans une démarche globale de
diminution des consommations de produits
phyto comme beaucoup de mes voisins dans
notre association il ya des gens qui
sont en bio donc par nature il en est
qu'il va non plus il ya des gens qui se
posent la question de convertir une
partie de leurs fermes ont bien aussi
donc voilà c'est impossible de faire
sans mais un mouvement il faut that
alors de faire sans le bon c'est une
problématique aussi réglementée en
france et quart et qu'on ne peut pas ou
très difficilement faire sur une même
ferme du bio et du pain bio donc
beaucoup de personnes qui sont
actuellement système conventionnel qui
voudraient tester le bio finalement
quelque part ça c'est compliqué de
tester sur 10 15 20 % de la ferme parce
que on n'a pas la possibilité d'un
commentaire aujourd'hui de le faire sauf
à créer différentes structures mais ce
qui complique l'aspect comptable c'est
donc donc c'est en train de changer
je trouve que la professeure des écoles
communique mal sur le fait justement
qu'il ya déjà des résultats qui a déjà
des choses qui se font sur le terrain et
en plus qui s'engagent pour voilà et
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a créé
l'association terre des yvelines c'est
pour faire savoir qu'on met des choses
en place sur nos fermes mesures et
méchant amoureux des produits non
clairement mais avoir l'impression
malheureusement c'est l'impression que
ça donne effectivement par spurs a
souvent été la politique de l'autruche
dans nos écoles on a été accusée montrés
du doigt et puis à part mettre la tête
sous la terre on n'a pas pas su répondre
je pense qu'on n'avait pas non plus des
chiffres pour pouvoir argumenter nous
nos actions et c'est l'occasion vous
avez pu le faire en tout cas mardi soir
puisque le glyphosate a été également
abordée mardi soir donc à
saint-nom-la-bretèche lors d'une réunion
publique locale sur les états généraux
de l'alimentation associations
agriculteurs et politiques ont pu
échanger sur les enjeux autour notamment
de la plaine de versailles à
l'initiative de deux députés aient des
yvelines les précisions avec ce
reportage
bien loin des polémiques européenne sur
le glyphosate localement habitants élus
associations et agriculteurs de la
plaine de versailles planchent sur les
enjeux agricoles de leur territoire un
territoire prisé avec douze nouvelles
exploitations qui se sont installés
récemment un record en ile-de-france
qu'il est nécessaire de préserver ce que
représente la plaine de versailles est
un système de biodiversité dans tous les
sens du terme et que pour qu'on puisse
avoir une nourriture de qualité il faut
que les acteurs c'est-à-dire les
agriculteurs mais aussi les
consommateurs jouent le jeu
comment favoriser la consommation locale
comment produire de façon responsable et
satisfaire la demande des consommateurs
la soirée s'est déroulée autour de trois
tables rondes et a permis de soulever de
nombreuses problématiques autour du
modèle agricole actuel
l'objectif est en fait de réussir à
montrer que le cahier des charges en
agriculture française est vertueux sain
et assure vraiment un gage de fiabilité
et de et de sécurité alimentaire
organisée par deux députés de la
république en marche cette réunion
publique s'inscrit dans le cadre des
états généraux de l'alimentation lancé
il ya quatre mois partout en france
objectif rapprocher l'ensemble des
acteurs de la filière
ce qui m'a vraiment motivé aujourd'hui
c'est de voir
ce renouveau dans l'agriculture ces
jeunes agriculteurs qui s'investissent
ce qui m'a plu aussi c'est de voir qu'il
y avait juste des consommateurs qui sont
venus aujourd'hui qui sont en demande
qui sont en attente d'une solution sur
des circuits courts qui ont besoin
d'informations sans calendrier fixe pour
le moment les états généraux de
l'alimentation devrait déboucher sur un
projet de loi dès le premier semestre
2010 8 dominique tristan vous étiez
présent mardi soir à saint nom la
bretèche sur des débats parfois très
techniques quand on n'est pas
spécialiste de ce sujet est ce que c'est
vraiment utile ce genre de rendez vous
est ce que ça permet vraiment de faire
avancer les choses concrètement quel est
l'avantagé l'avantagent pensait que
certes c'est un buteur qui parlait mais
pas à des agriculteurs ou pas que à des
éditeurs ça permet de c'était la
communication dont vous alors peut-être
de faire un échange sur finalement
quelles sont nos problématiques
et puis comme pourquoi on est perçu
comme ça et puis quels seront nos
visions à court moyen terme de nos
systèmes et comment on évolue vis-à-vis
des contraintes ou des opportunités
qu'on peut avoir localement on en a
entendu l'information dans le reportage
12 nouvelles exploitations sur les
dernières années sur la plaine de
versailles un record en ile de france
comment vous expliquez entre guillemets
un tel succès alors la première chose
c'est que ce sont des terrains alors les
paires sont rares parce qu'en fait il ya
très peu très peu de mouvements foncier
en ile de france habituellement et
s'arrête là on a eu la chance d'avoir
beaucoup de vente de foncier des
propriétaires qui voulait plus continuer
et automatiquement
ça a permis à des acteurs de se
positionner pour de l'installation et
avec la chance d'avoir deux
installations effectivement dans un
territoire qui est quand même
relativement petit et des productions
très diversifié c'est aussi votre
intérêt oui on a vu les débats a porté
notamment sur justement consommer
produire plus plus de façon plus
responsable
comment consommer local ce sont des
choses qui sont simples à mettre pas à
mettre en place sur sur la plaine de
versailles vous le faites déjà par
exemple à la ferme de grignon est ce que
les autres exploitants par exemple on
pense à la vente en direct les safiots
qu est-ce que ici en ile de france et
peut-être plus simple de les mettre en
place que ailleurs est-ce que c'est plus
facile d'abord une agriculture
responsable ici que d'autres d'autres
endroits en france alors par rapport à
l'avant dirais que c est bon étant dans
l'île de france ouest
clairement c'est plus simple que si on
est en plein milieu de la beauce on a un
flux d'habitants même si c'est très bien
c'est un beau milieu de la tout à fait
toute la gauche mais pour la vente
directe c'est clair qu'on a des routes
où il ya 25 ou 30 mille voitures qui
passent par jour pour faire de la vente
directe c'est beaucoup plus simple de
prendre le risque de se lancer
donc après chaque acteur fait son son
diagnostic un peu stratégiques en
fonction justement ces fameuses
opportunité ou contraintes qui y assure
sur son territoire et sur son
implantation et puis bête se décide à
partir sur telle ou telle activité
qu'est-ce qui est très simple à mettre
en place aujourd'hui que peut-être tous
les agriculteurs sont vincent pointé
qui sont dans les yvelines ne font pas
par par mauvaises habitudes et lorsque
très simple ce qu'on sait rien de très
simple dès qu'on commence à toucher le
consommateur en direct il ya des
questions nouvelles qui viennent par
rapport à un métier classique de
producteurs agricoles je pense à la
transformation éventuelle je pense à la
commercialisation je pense à la
logistique
ça fait des bascules énorme de
trésorerie dès que vous commencez à voir
des stocks
malheureusement aujourd'hui les
trésoreries des rotations sans crème
rouge info parler concrètement et bat
toute situation financière tendue et
s'engager fait que c'est plus compliqué
de réfléchir un changement de système
c'est vraiment le point bloquant
aujourd'hui on a eu quand même une très
mauvaise mousson 2016 et des cours qui
depuis maintenant quatre ans quasiment
sont quand même plutôt relativement bas
une dernière réflexion une réponse assez
rapide parce qu'on n'y en a pas mal
avancé dans le temps est ce que
finalement ce ne sont pas les
consommateurs qui tiennent les cartes en
main pour une nouvelle agriculture plus
plus responsable est ce que on devrait
échanger le aux modes de consommation
peut être quitte à payer plus cher et à
manger moins pour aller plus vers de de
la nourriture de qualité oui alors je
pense effectivement ça passe par là
alors ça peut passer par là par la vente
directe puisque la jirs et un contact
direct sur la façon dont le producteur
fait son produit et la prévention doit
en avoir le consommateur permet de
retirer des craintes d après ans voilà
mais je pense que je peux faire aussi
sur des filières longues des filières
industrielles dans l'interview il avait
alexander welsh qui parlait de ça et je
suis persuadé que voilà aujourd'hui le
cadre réglementaire français fait que
l'alimentation est très saine et et ça
il faut faire valoir au niveau de la
vente des produits et arrêter cette
hypocrisie entre les produits importés
qui n'ont quasiment aucune règle qui se
retrouvent dans les linéaires de la même
façon que les produits qui sont sources
et en france et qui n'ont pas du tout
les mêmes contraintes de production
merci dominique de tristan d'être venu
en plateau je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur de la ferme expérimentale de
grignon et président de l'association
terre des eyzies vie merci à vous et bon
week-end merci on passe tout de suite à
l'actualité de la semaine
cette semaine d'actualité marquée par le
voyage des manuels maquereau en afrique
une première pour lui avec plusieurs
étapes au burkina faso en côte d'ivoire
et au ghana
le président de la république c'est
principalement adressé à la jeunesse
africaine dans un style très personnel
et qui lui a permis de mieux cerner les
difficultés du continent selon issam
thiam le président de l'association des
ressortissants africains de saint
quentin en yvelines
il était sur notre plateau jeudi soir
écoutez le le président étant jeune il a
voulu essentiellement s'adresser à la
jeunesse africaine pour son voyage
famille donc
oui dépoussiérer pourtant ça pas été
voyage également simple pour lui je
pense un il a quand même eu vu
l'opposition une opposition en afrique
assure pas mal de problèmes qui nous dit
le quotidien
certes il n'en est pas responsable mais
également des les actions passées de la
france en afrique
à plaisir le projet de réaménagement du
centre ville suit son cours des
concertations organisées avec des
habitants lundi soir une dernière
réunion publique avait lieu à la mairie
l'occasion de faire le point sur les
différentes idées évoquées précédemment
et les pistes envisagées pour ce projet
structurant pour la commune les
précisions avec camille lambert
c'est un projet d'envergure auquel se
préparent la ville de plaisir la
requalification de son centre ville
trois secteurs sont particulièrement
concernés le quartier du vélib ou la
zone de l'hôpital charcot et le centre
historique
une évolution conséquente pour les
plaisirs oies et c'est justement avec
eux que la mairie souhaite travailler
elle a organisé trois réunions publiques
destinées aux habitants
au moins je suis plus intéressé par la
refonte les le projet du centre ville
sur le site de l'hôpital charcot donc
comme j'habite juste en face donc jusqu
aux premières loges donc s'il ya des
maisons des immeubles qui vont être
construits ça m'intéresse au plus haut
point à savoir jusqu'où
cet aménagement va aller au niveau de
cette ville comment ça va se passer
des interrogations nombreuses même si
l'heure est toujours à la concertation
que croit car encore des personnes qui
pensent que ce sont déjà des résultats
et des décisions que nous avons prises
alors que non nous ne sommes que dans
une phase diagnostic
on est dans une dans une discussion dans
un échange pour vous justement
imaginez ce qu'on pourrait faire 6 sur
la ville il y avait des choses qui
allaient se libérer
parce que la fusion des deux hôpitaux
fait qu' il y a beaucoup de foncier qui
se libèrent actuellement et on va pas
laisser faire n'importe quoi parmi les
pistes évoquées
l'aménagement du ru le prolongement
d'une coulée verte et la création de
liaisons douces
concernant le valley bout la
réhabilitation a déjà commencé pour
casser d'enfermement du quartier de la
ville prévoit de nouveaux cheminements
et la création d'une place avec
différents commerces
il ya plusieurs coulées vertes ya
plusieurs il ya la coulée bleus et puis
il ya également toute cette installation
des pistes cyclables que nous souhaitons
mettre d'agrandir les trottoirs et puis
aussi de remettre et de repositionner
les commerces de proximité on a la
chance d'avoir une zone commerciale très
intense mais il faut aussi que l'on
maintienne et que l'on développe tout
cet espace qui est l'espace des
commerces de proximité
favoriser les petits commerces une
demande des habitants
elle concerne également le centre
historique un projet important qui
devrait se concrétiser d'ici 20 à 25 ans
les plaisirs oies sont toujours invités
à laisser leurs avis et leurs questions
sur le site plaisir de nos points comme
depuis le 1er novembre les démarches
pour le pacs se simplifie le pacte civil
de solidarité se conclut désormais chez
le notaire ou en mairie c'est une mesure
de la loi de modernisation de la justice
du 21e siècle les communes
saint-quentinoise sont déjà fortement
sollicités
mélanie poké a pu suivre la signature
d'un pacs à plaisir une petite signature
pour une nouvelle étape après quatre ans
de vie commune sigrid et pascal se sont
pacsés cette semaine à plaisir depuis le
1er novembre les officiers d'état civil
peuvent enregistrer le pacte civil de
solidarité des pour les
à versailles était beaucoup trop long et
c'est vrai qu'on s'est passé au 1er
novembre à la mairie on a dit que on
allait attendre cette date là c'est une
démarche plus simple pour nous une
nouveauté qui semble intéresser les
plaisirs oies en seulement un mois 17
dossiers ont été déposés le délai actuel
dans cette commune une quinzaine de
jours les agents ont été formés via la
préfecture
et c'est rentré aussi dans le plan de
formation continue que nous avons la
ville de plaisir
donc nous avons formé pour l'instant
trois agents mais à terme tous les
agents d'administration générale seront
formés pour la signature du pacs un
dossier de pacs peut être pré remplie
sur le site internet service public.fr
il doit ensuite être déposé en mairie un
message de prévention avant de se
quitter
faites attention si vous empruntez la
route ce week-end avec le retour du
froid de la neige et du verglas les
dangers se multiplient pensez à adaptez
votre conduite vigilance aussi si vous
empruntez la ligne l du transilien ce
week-end
aucun train ne circulera entre samedi 12
heures et dimanche de 12h donc pendant
24 heures en raison de travaux pour le
grand paris express pour trouver un
autre trajet consulter le site
transilien.com c'est la fin de ce set 8
l'hebdo autour de l'information en
direct lundi à 18h sur l'antenne de tv
78 d'ici là restez connectés et informés
grâce à notre application tv 78 notre
site internet
bon week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]